Android has changed
a lot over the years,
from the classic Android
design, through Holo,
and now material design.
How do you build an app that
looks great and consistent
across all these devices
and Android versions?
That's where AppCompat comes in,
giving you a consistent theme
and baseline for
your applications
that stays in sync with the
latest version of Android.
Hi, I'm Ian Lake.
I'm here to tell you about
the features of AppCompat,
how to get started, and why
it's one of the keys to building
apps faster.
So how exactly do you
transform our default state
into something great?
In fact, there's only
two changes needed.
The first part is
the AppCompat theme.
It encapsulates all of the
version specific logic for you,
giving you just a
single theme to use.
The second part is the
switch to AppCompat activity,
and this is what gives
us a consistent action
bar, contextual action modes,
and support for toolbars,
as well as the features of
its parent class, fragment
activity, including
fragments and loaders.
And just like that, we have
a single, consistent look
and feel that works on
over a billion devices.
Not bad.
But the default theme is
only a starting point.
AppCompat brings the material
color palette to all devices,
making it easy to
bring your brand's
color into every
part of your app
with a single, simple theme.
Let's create a theme and
set the three main colors.
Color primary, which
controls the action bar
coloring, and should be
your main branding color.
Color primary dark,
which is a darker
variant of your primary
color, and used to color
the status bar on
platforms that support it.
And color accent, which actually
provides the accent coloring
for views, such as checkboxes,
edit text, and radio buttons.
So how does our coloring look?
Pretty good.
You'll notice that
all of our widgets
now use our custom coloring.
You'll also get backward
compatible versions
of alert dialogue, search
view, share action provider,
contextual action
modes, and toolbars,
giving you a consistent set
of the latest and greatest
components, so you don't have
to compromise your design
to support all of your users.
So how do you get AppCompat into
your project in Android Studio?
It's easy.
The templates for new
projects and new activities
automatically include
AppCompat, giving you
the basics by default. If you
have an existing project you
want to switch over, you'll
add a single dependency
to your build.gradle
file, change your theme,
move over to AppCompat activity,
and replace a few method
calls with their support
library equivalents,
hopefully removing a bunch
of version specific code
in the process.
With AppCompat giving
you a consistent base,
you can focus on what
makes your app unique.
We've touched on
just a few things
that you get through AppCompat.
You can learn more about
the Android support
library and AppCompat
on the developer site.